oh I'm Stewart Brand along a foundation
and this is moving in the second year
seminars about long-term thinking
back in the early 90s 10 diboll the book
called age weight and now that's an
organization based here at San Francisco
called a day later and usually he's
speaking to corporate uh places or
government audiences to people who are
basically realizing that the demographic
the United States is changing profoundly
one more people who are living longer
and doing stuff differently with their
extended health it's not they're taking
longer time to diets that they're
staying fresh and engaged and having
sequences of couriers sometimes
marriages sometimes sets of children and
society that was built around 70 75 year
lifespan is not
so that's changing we hadn't talked last
one of my quest on the prospects of
human life extension and he was talking
about a young blood very serious way or
he can read you in blood an old person
an opportunity of the blood around
artisan tissues that have encounters
just one of the half a dozen major
strategic paths that lengthened human
health I think human life is coming is
coming fast so we set up the sequence of
talks to the first microwave starting up
the prospects of human life extension
and in the aging expert can die call to
talk about the consequences microphone
is on let's chill our right good say
what before I get started recess people
come tonight
city boy this is our time hello summer
and particularly want to learn okay I
got a reason for coming
speaking about hi
living forever who actually like to live
forever they would prefer not to live
great summer got a little more out on
the river and wander through how many do
you play that depends you might go in a
cemetery
we'll get to that was that support you
can see them yes okay on that yes we'll
go there we'll come back
yes Lisa
the topic is a frontier
what would we do patella tearing is
normal
cares about my work
it had rain over institution as long as
you develop a stroke what would be a
people that won't record to that means
that land itself a particular kind of
political infrastructure or a certain
thing hello yes way back
so I'm curious to know
I'm
yeah complexity of the audience you've
got about 10 to 15 zipper just put out
there versus all the same so these are
all parts of this interesting diagram
with and many more yes out of hand ha I
thought about in terms of how would it
affect people's mental active living it
really extended time it's going to
change your education your knees or your
spirits around sexuality complete change
three or four year long
yeah lucky moment
this time past 70 and she talked
well one more well we got two more yeahh
time we felt like our time
an interesting point interview had a
hundred years would you be in such a
hurry to question on my map tonight
I
years I came top few years ago in Los
Angeles and I am out in front about
2,000 people years I've million people
books and so I need to pace an hour
before i speaking with gods and all I've
ever given a presentation like we were
yet for tonight with my actual clothes
dress up like they're kind of micronesia
well I'd live here the various i thought
either come with myself right there cha
it is talking pitched around outside
going for me was about a thousand people
inside a guy who thought we said repent
dipole brighton finally he said what
every father you're working on a fitness
instructor and I've got one of my
clients who am i really love you and I
said you know about start time maybe
Africa's done and I've got music Scott
so I said find this that's I can make
I've set up understand true story and he
looked about 75 not working the view of
gerontology is my fourth decade of just
begun in the skills are a lot of people
of various stages and he would press f5
to me pretty physically
who I very clear of mortising name is
better times and even working out and
shake ya got into it I feel really
pretty how long you been working out
well I'd buy back a week do it for two
years to start and he said well my
energy never do want to be strong for
what happened said to how old do you
start and he says 102 sorry that the
next year he entered into the sea ruined
this is a seminarian category and every
single event in which he participated he
set a new world record like a minute but
it was in the world record for for me of
the future which is those of us who are
70 or 90 or 100 or 110 Midway's overly
women of the new frontier and the new
frontier is not about me I'm here to
tell you I don't believe it's about
technology I think Evan and I also
believe that village every revolution at
the end of the day will have a bigger
impact on who we are how we think how we
feel what we do have only do it how long
we love who we love how many career we
have the instant economic infrastructure
of the global community leadership then
either the industrial or technological
revolutions in previous centuries this
is a very big one so I'm going to do
this evening first of all I want to say
that come here to be Stuart but I don't
usually very often speak instead of
anything
local gathering with Stewart branded me
an icon big thinking Brandi has been a
part of so many different movements
and I would also point out that I is 23
i wrote my vertical fine when i was 22
when I was 23 I I moved vertically to
work with illuminated gateways to create
a project that we all we call the sage
project but what we started they were a
group of us before the study group but
we didn't know anything about anything
but we made up so we called ourselves a
holistic health counselor from which she
knows Kent pelletier American gang
leaders of myself and Eric pepper and
lemon woman Stanwyck element in
characters like that and we didn't know
how to set ourselves up as about the
profit so there was a fabulous devil
that came along came a group of two
thousand dollars and help us get set up
and to a friend so wonderful waited
world turns and twists on itself 30
years later
later Stuart so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to wander through a variety of
things getting paid I can try new things
out this evening and if it doesn't work
out you can't complain I got my interest
is less in how to live to be a hundred
revival and the gas reasonably
uncomplicated relatively uncomplicated
my issues have always been so NY new
early in my career I was not leave
in sort of a wellness side of health and
longevity but also all the technological
breakthroughs that might be coming it
certainly is environment the US Congress
they only make engage spent several
years I think I've mary's medical
technologies on the future of global
democracy and at that point became
obviously people are living longer and
longer that seemed to me to be pretty
easy consideration more efficient one
was well what is that family only work
when does the person senior of his old
age begin what do you do with all those
16 years back to school how do you
contend with the society that's
reasonably disrespectful for aging in is
deeply germaphobic the beginning Who am
I as individual when I'm 20 or 50 or 70
in a loss of life so tonight I'm going
to water to remember those things apart
of it will be hopefully amusing other
parts might cause you to think about
everything you think about differently
that would be my home and at least one
point during the course this evening for
each of you i will get some place inside
of your hand move
he might get to the entertaining part so
I actually never shown before maybe some
of you are familiar with these these are
done in 1842 by Thomas Cole over journey
of life four part series and I quickly
tell you with what they look like to me
they look like some of your senses of an
eye on with this is the first one that
is meant to reflect beginning of life
infancy perhaps childhood as you can see
you've got this child instead of kind of
joy and this boat was an angel seem to
be steering taken by the clarity of the
flora fauna immediacy of all these
wonderful colors sort of the beginning
of life in this painting and then you
get into young adulthood and you see
that the angel was stepped out of both
the own of beings got his or her hand on
the rudder seems to be steering his or
her own ship you can see vast dimensions
of panoramas and there's a sense of
dream in one's future there's a sort of
mystical castle and then we hit sort of
state that many of us are in now
male adults of where the runners broken
can't find the angel very easily with
back up there but not quite a friend the
trauma prejudice torment uncertainty
darkness worth all the great stuff see
lots of rocks and then you enter into
the final stage of life old age which
Daniels returned and is sort of painting
you off to another angel and as you can
see the material world at the ministry
importance in the sort of the Scourge
world equis fabulous okay quite an
interest story unto themselves but they
also established context and the context
is you have a certain number of years if
you do this maybe do that you're done
and that's an interesting model and it
happens to be the model in which most of
our lives have been contextualized so
let's switch to the idea of increasing
longevity and you know this idea of a
fountain of youth have been around for a
long time in fact if you go to the
source of many of today's modern
religions they were based on the idea
that there was somehow the possibility
of purification of oneself there were
these legends of magical waters and
ponce de leon searching for fountain
view extraordinary location spices herbs
in fact on the discovery by the
Europeans of america
fine herbs and spices to make tasty
curry but rather these were supposedly
spices that would bestow immortality
that my many the early explorers we're
really looking for longevity that was a
game the idea that why is it was sick
wiser died someplace somewhere there's a
cure for that there's a remedy truther
there's thousands of years he will
pursue these anti aging or white
expanding technologies with essentially
no diesel and wasn't really until we
started cleaning our streets that the
revolution always interesting to me
people r imagine some extraordinary
breakthrough lady was talked about by
dr. West last month but you know a
friendly he's got you made the biggest
in fact in that thousand year period at
our public health departments the
arrival of antibiotics the distribution
of medicine for the first time anybody
tell me what this is a picture up I want
if I were to show in your kid's picture
they wouldn't know what science fiction
movie yeah three kids see they did I am
your kids I don't
about 30 I Labrador book with Jonas Salk
and one night over dinner you call me
the story at the 1940s the belief was
that the future would be filled with
more room to more senators because
poliomyelitis which is rampant and keep
in mind holy-o's hey gets water horns
and you couldn't forget upon pounds
could go public pools you wouldn't touch
people imagine age x 100 and then but he
thought know what we have to do is put
an end to life shortly white
debilitating geez and break through 53
and 55 the annihilation began and now
most of us live in a life or we don't
know anybody as a result of thousands of
years to pursue in at least one solid
century of grapefruits we now have all
old people two-thirds of all the men
women who ever lived past 65 by our
history of the world or alive today so
I'm going to offer a point of view that
it's probably different than what you
thought come again I'm going to alter a
little later but we're already in a
longevity revolution we're already
experiencing life attention it's a
little bit like a sausage machine and
the one that you put in better science
better medicine better health better
control the environment whatever it is
you're doing what comes out the other
hand is old people
I was on a show us your caper again well
how do we know the longevity revolution
is happening that's a really interesting
question because you don't live longer
now credit to making critical you live
longer than so if you were to have your
life extended you still be say maybe you
are right now so how do you know how do
you know there's a longevity resolution
happening because you're at the gym and
there's a 72 year old lady on the
treadmill next to you and she's going
faster than you orange you're not
sweating because 250,000 people forget
about the courses last year because
people are not taking their second
careers after their time because
grandparents go skiing with your
grandkids because people go through
identity crises according to get 80
these are all the signs and symptoms of
a revolution that's already underway if
you look at this chart I think you have
to be struck by the fact that over the
past 1,000 years the average life
expectation which a thousand years ago
25 birth and on the first day of the
20th century was 47 we've had quite a
remarkable leap in the last century in
navy you think oh we're just so used to
it it's no big deal that's a very big
deal I'm going to put this in context
I'm going to back this up for the
student grandbabies the room and show
you the average life expectation at
Birth charted over the past 100 thousand
years medical anthropologist now houses
ninety-nine percent of all human history
the average life expectation world what
has been less than 18 years so the point
of is that throughout all of history
people did age they got some people live
to before
ready but they were paragraph know in
order to me to sort of get to where idea
to being hold on to the question I hope
will be a bunch now this is it first I'm
sure one of the questions is well yeah
but if you're already 40 or 50 have you
really been a beneficiary or I think
change the truth of it is that the
numbers of people now will and can
expect to live 50 or 70 or 90 is
multiplied I want to tell you that power
name of 20th century I called the age
weight century or the longevity century
the most extraordinary change that's
happened in human evolution over the
past hundred thousand years is right
there now we get over the morning
expecting expected to live 75 or 80
enjoy meters she was never did we are
the beneficiaries of a longevity
revolution in fact since it's actually
since eighteen fifty but if you're
looking from 1904 every decade it's past
the average life expectation of birth is
elevated about two and a half years and
that's an interesting dynamic because if
you look at things like Social Security
and Medicare there are further
assumptions upon which economic
infrastructure of our built and one of
the assumptions which by the way no they
asked either presidential candidate in
the last election unbelievable is what
are the assumptions upon a longevity
upon which these infrastructures they're
built and by the way you should know
that they're based on these
that will not be one great big medicine
in the next 50 years the 50 years now
the average life expectancy will be
about two maybe three or higher than is
trivial so the interesting point is what
if we live what if we just keep going in
this case it means that if you're
already 50 in the average life
expectancy for 50 rolls and a tease but
if it keeps elevated by the time you're
eighty three decades 70 half years up so
it might be 90 by there and it's what
happened to have a little bit of
Education a little bit of money you can
take care of yourself no better than the
average person living to 90 or 95 we're
just normal folk is not that extreme now
that's not nearly as dramatic as some of
the technologies longer tell you about a
little later such as voice like a lesson
that involved with where there's some
radical shifting but just the idea that
we're even talking about many of us
within 90 200 years is quite
extraordinary when most futurist mission
the future they somehow have this dog
barks on blind-spot of an angel so the
future is usually objections future
young people and then they're rock chips
with skin tight office but this is not
the like the future but if the notes of
the Friday evening we've got a bear me
prouder if you go up to it I actually
show you a picture of the future we got
later the blue dresses serif now she's
118 sitting across from her is her
daughter kitty she's maybe five standing
up in the back of her dress on bob 73
they're like well damn skippy in this
statement there's happy she's a great by
the daughter of 49 then you've got
Kristina's the great-great-granddaughter
27 a little brown
generation 3 this is the future clearly
glamorous as the future which everybody
looks when you're 18 but is the likely
future some of you hit it with your
questions yet idea of having four five
six generations alive once have we got
as far as to going to go I don't think
so i think what about a second inning of
a 90 you game with regard to this one
gently revolution diving in this blonde
magazines of those one side of the face
is utopia sundays for 40 years older
this notion of can we somehow manipulate
aging or since most people anybody's
ever died of old age what people seem to
die for diseases these are conceivable
that more of us might have a chance of
about our biological tential of about
120 years and the way to get to that is
to move away or compress the diseases
that not have found so that we can do
the oliver wendell holmes one more
shaping and the volunteers in a day and
then have everything seems great because
what's knocking my mom and dad and our
elder relatives I'm so much AG its
disease it's the cave the client is
filled is wearing on the parts it's a
little like having two cars that you buy
on the same day one of you know I get
one of you and I
I take care of a pair of mine I dig it
up change the oil you take really good
care of yours although maybe be opposite
them apart person but so the end of 10
years our heart or both 10 years old the
mind is not falling apart and you still
pretty good shape so Lord what we're
having two separate out what is the
aging what is disease because we have
two conceivable games to play one of
them is to eliminate or postpone disease
so that we without our potential the
other stuff all the aging process itself
maybe get back both of them later on
another interesting point that I want to
mention because for me this issue it's
got so many more open legs to it I want
at least have us appreciate some of the
dimensions when I got involved in the
field of gerontology all people work
toward third the elderly live below the
poverty line in 1960s turns out today
the elderly of the river at the lowest
power level of any age group of the
country of ten point four percent as a
point of reference young people today at
the poverty level of twenty one percent
mascara filters they give you have all
the money as it turns out on the old 60
goals tend not to look like this thing
where they increasingly look like this
in fact if you break it out of 50 plus
population people over 50 ml control
seventy percent of all the wealth
regions like Europe much of Asia
certainly North America master they
bought fifty five percent of all the
luxury cars any percent of all the
luxury travel seventy-four percent of
prescription drive 60
medicines by 20 bucks in multiple ways
with your grandchildren what you guys
are very interesting phenomena which is
that the oldest segment of our society
has become the most active the only
eighty percent of all the money savings
alone institutions six and six cents of
every dollar invested in the equity
markets is invested by people over 50
which then they just asked a very
interesting question which is how can we
get all the discounts
because if you at least some time when
you're driving over you're taking a
shower or you're thinking about things
you can think that would prove it's a
very interesting puzzle and it has
really nothing to do with elder poverty
which is a myth there are cycles of
poverty among older people particularly
want people over 75 particularly women
of color but in generally after 60 50 of
America's going really well that's a
great triumph the fact that down
multiply 40 times in the course of their
lives the fact of benefits that multiply
from tournaments the union negotiations
after war of some people in better
circumstances and also this is the
generation that hasn't grown up in the
shadow of the depression was very
inclined safe because there was a sphere
of something catastrophic happening and
now their minds and by the way property
about the growing between five and seven
hundred percent in the course of their
lives so it's a good thing that's not a
bad thing about a lot of people would
like you to Joe tell me don't tell
anybody older people have money tell the
truth here nobody go people have no
medical insurance at all and we're told
the person get 7000 Fox Theater benefits
last election happily we're talking
about making sure the young people got
the strip to drugs why do people tend to
vote their age about thirty percent of
32 year old boat instead p % 7 year old
and so one of the great the chewier
dynamics is going on is that while the
marketplaces remain you focused
literally we have become a guru khakhra
see we are a gyro khakhra see the
candidates know who inflated they know
you want to win votes here's the group
you told you to give more stuff that can
arrange a realistic set of
considerations because when our founding
fathers and mothers constructed this
interesting democracy of checks and
balances
concerned about church and state about
political parties about different
dimensions of government and they were
all strong extranaras are set up to keep
each other in line life expectancy was
certified and data declaration than
predators some people were 50 and 60 and
70 but they were very few and so I
hadn't really occurred to the founding
fathers that there might be a time when
25 year olds and 75 the world's would
have their interests imbalance in the
political sphere so what happens if we
have a world where there is increasing
over the volatile people who are
increasingly self-centered from
self-indulgent who basically want the
resources to be spent on them can't even
imagine that not being fair what does
that do well it's already happened and
last year from federal taxes for every
dollar spent procedure there was eleven
cents spend per child I love that
somebody explain to me how thats Sarah
now the kids are in school that I was
afraid people don't want to meet you
after school programs that no funding
people don't even make the connection
do I respect older people and 30 years
of my life advocate i think is some
dishonesty going on yeah generates
another interesting question which is
how old is old because the answer to
this question turns the entire social
and political and psychologic economic
infrastructure of the modern world right
now we use the number 65 why well
because in the 88th is Bismarck was
drafting your suspensions when he had a
big name people would be so enfeebled so
disabled they really couldn't work life
expectancy that year was 45 so we were
using the same equation today we'd be
retiring people today if you simply end
20 years at 97 so but we we call people
hold it 65 then they become eligible for
old-age benefits so what 65 today well
spoken the round of 65 today to give you
a framework res mom she's right around
multiple choice deals they're up in his
face of 77 fire going two months ago
front of the senator totally cool and
when he went to run now she's going up
into space I was asked by seeming to do
the commentary what do people think of
that took a lot of people there was a
publicity gimmick to try to get funneled
to NASA and he had a really interesting
reaction you said wait night just
because off in 77 doesn't mean I don't
have dreams 77 still has other things
they want to do i put the dreams will
for young people dreams are what you had
when you were young then you neither
succeeded never failed and then you come
out past the time before you die 77 year
old with dreams that's a pizza longevity
record by the way they do your mom who
wants to learn how to surf the internet
you know it may be your cousin who
trying to fall in love because her
husband passed away 62 cancer it may be
the 90 year old who was trying to make
some good friends it's hard to imagine
but the new frontier is old maturity is
the new frontier and so what is the
77-year old sean connery's hook insert a
sexy guy is a decade of life Lena marks
filtering
main decade of life and I'll ask you a
simple question here if I want to do a
survey today and your job with come up
with an age for the 21st century about
the 19th century then mark the beginning
of old age if could be lets say here
java pick one we need to pick 65 70 75
80 85 let's do a boat how many of you
for that Bismarck's job knowing what you
know now about how people are living in
how long you're living in the
possibilities in maturity I'm gonna do a
pic 65 hey anybody pics 70 anybody pics
75 they make the gate anyway the kids
are okay great now I've asked that
question probably about 500,000 people
and into those the background saying
it's somewhere around 80 85 people think
of old age because unless I'm talking to
seniors and then there's about life is
higher hey they've all days older than
that unless there's free stuff they can
because you watch the issues when
whatever president says we need to raise
the retirement age 72 or 75 people go
preserve but if our city what do you
want me to think of you that all the
person you come to be bless you I think
what do you want to get all these
entitlements which is what those are oh
it's a very interesting issue 14 which
societies of dots you make some sense
because it on the other hand older
people control a boat and they want all
that stuff then you've got a peculiar
kind of Juran to product and balance
that the world has never have to
encounter before then it's a very
sensitive own because if anyone gets up
and does the anti broke off wait a
minute great generation but how much you
think given how much Nick getting let's
discuss this get bashed you're an elder
alligator you're disrespectful to you I
not I think Walter people but old age is
not what it used to be
another registry issue a women are
biologically superior to men as you guys
I'm sure are well aware available animal
species out the man so what we're seeing
in addition to this sort of new model
the journey is a guy that you hear when
we pass away these women with new modern
women of the Sun you ever go through a
period of very deep grief and
bereavement for about a year
it's your fault regional their
investment portfolio often to get better
returns and they form of a silver-haired
Amazonian tribes and no I don't be
surprised with the future groups of
women start coming together now Jimmy
wall lying employment there's Noah's Ark
thing see the Noah's Ark amount of work
and there was one who I for every girl
or that was supposed to be the right
thing but there's not enough guy so
woman's son was get a house together why
not what's wrong with that well because
you've got a little bit of a leftover
the depression mentality for having your
own home with no borders was considered
a great son success our grandparents
that really matter your own home now
you've got a bathroom 20 million seniors
living all by themselves in big houses
are big of artists lonely get a bunch of
people really care about it someplace
together in the mountains are going to
place in Manhattan or have replaced but
the idea of women then tribes of women
becoming the new power bases the future
of operation you see if you go to
retirement communities by the way will
be aligned on the movies together or on
cruise ships you know the route of
travel when you get sick they nourish
and caregiver ever invested in circles
so you might say that matter wants to
talk about life extension I am
another interesting challenge because
Madison Avenue in 1946 and what about
million television sets the modern
marketing and advertising hasn't yet
ilysm there's enough and then the
Boomers came along and used to kinda
thing and everybody thought the use of
the target and old people were kind of
poor silly influence of waking inverter
tomatoes and elder characters and what
you're beginning to see if you notice
that because of the financial wealth of
the mature population there's a whole
new category bags started to appear in
media here's an example
Oh
here's a world in here 2000 most
countries in dark blue Europe and Japan
already have more than twenty percent of
the population over 60 by the way
there's and other pieces puzzle but i'll
only mentioned because we've only got so
much time tonight but at the same time
the countries are experiencing
increasing longevity testing the same
countries are experiencing decreasing
fertility so for example the fertility
rate that required her country simply
maintaining sizes about 2.1 kids per
couple the battle we are in the united
states there's not one country in europe
recognize have been able to replace
themselves those in London three weeks
ago the birth rate is 1.6 serving is 1.5
Italy it's 1.2 and 1.3 last year so
you've got this amazing dynamic where
you see the number of young people
literally shrinking Japan is going to
depopulate soon as a third of its
population you know in four years now
and increasingly becoming old by the way
one of the potential solutions that is
to radically offer altered immigration
policy to balance the equation so here's
push family years ago wish that I would
rather stimulate more information people
now all jazzed up about I can't do that
as a garbage out believe it or not there
are people in that administration who
understand that demographic weighting is
so treacherous that you need simulate
integration sort of like patented us go
to Japan with it got an on immigration
policy it's very dangerous how do you
work on a question i'm going to show you
2025 watch the watch the dark blue all
the modernizations the world are better
about this age way and i want to make a
point about this has never happened
before everything about the revolution
has never happened before every single
pieces so those of you who like
innovation those of you who like to come
up with no idea those you like to think
about things that have not that are not
retraced that's some time with this one
it's a blast
i'll add another dimension to the story
because the next group of people who
migrate through maturity are the boom
generation so why are you seeing all
these anti aging wrinkle cream because
all the romance went over half a century
ago there's a direct connection between
the two let me put this in perspective
during the 1930s and 40s I know you guys
know the demographics place on this
swiftly there was a depression in the
war of birth rate low war ended the boys
came home 76 million kids record in the
next 18 years and always would ski that
those kids were conceived on that
weekend keep in mind through the baby
boomers followed by a bust and then
followed by an echo boo we were
unprepared we didn't have enough
pediatricians under the boss in the room
the one of the hospitals weren't enough
berkeley zones of babies were being born
lobbies and waiting rooms the kids came
home there weren't enough ever lead
generation that has dedicated her cover
two kids per couple boomer generation
for kids for couple families and before
you know it they had a explosion not
just in babies but young families now
how would have come to you in the 1940s
let's put on your investment at first
sight I never told you that every eight
seconds baby will be born as 10,000 a
day four million years to go on 13 years
what do you want to do about that let's
do some investing because that's a
pretty predictable phenomenal
I said let's address another is coming
I've never heard of them I said they're
a new company they're going to formulate
a didn't put it in jars and have you
been a traditional finger you with
several mothers do that themselves by
pre-made food understand notice
modernization things in the catch fire
and these moms having 14 feet he's so
busy during the pilot pre formulated or
I would have taken you to New Brunswick
to the J&J company which had a vision
focused our product called wound care
strip but a sidewalks were being laid
down all these little types from
scraping your knees maybe the US 1951
they relaunched their product rather
than a band-aid sold a lot of that let's
say you're interested in real estate I
visited those farm regions we have
eternity of the sprawling suburbs it
makes money like biochemist rather than
a traditional home either son Chris of
mine John 54 Chris had terrible case of
pimples in the 1960s and I didn't live
up the screen he put a little son's face
made pimples dry up you notice of
Christmas class was overcrowded and get
some Oh Marcus over 4 million kids born
that year and the next and the next I by
the way to nineteen sixties if you have
acne you can ask
getdescription product or rub alcohol
couldn't go to score by Clearasil was I
say you like food service business I
would introduce you to uh well geezer
guy but they call people who work in
their fifties he was 56 insulting
lenders in Southern California to diners
and Ray but he spent so much time on
these restaurants you go to all these
what was going to hurt the curtain and
what the world needed was fast eating
restaurants this Prince's you're crazy
he already confessed but Ray Kroc
lessons in the fountain for the
hamburgers in the rest is history
boomers also went through their
rebellious here every generation had a
little systemic values miss but when you
got 76 million kids going through it at
the same time a little bit of Atlas it
can become a revolution generation also
split out those parents during that
period having to do with a war having to
do with philosophy of global
intervention it was a peculiar time to
come of age the time not particularly to
trust leadership they live here too
restrained in this generation is their
willingness to believe that they're
being lied to by authority figures and
therefore their relatives go around the
traditional keep that in mind when we
get in a little while I gave viable
generate sometimes people say 'he doctor
guy well where were you in the late
sixties in 1967 I grew up in Newark New
Jersey
I can make another brief statement about
California I can't the Caliph 197 to the
psychological client big circle 74 the
berkeley marina i came out here for
psychological intellectual plan which
probably entirely out of line with what
I'm about to say somehow she flew
backwards in the last 10 or 15 years
somehow that all caught up with
technology which is really great and did
not create a big sucking sound and it
became about money and he came back
flash quick ideas and somehow to cycle
out of an intellectual planet where did
it go and so once the word indicated he
was partly in many new year of trying to
bring back sort of an intellectual
environment of new ideas and interesting
just gonna knock things around but I
wouldn't be great to be a particular
particular preference I'm just referring
to for me the attraction of California
not a nice weather although that's great
in fact cool attractions here there was
the idea that there were ideas stir here
big Fox beautiful and I'd love to see
more not a home birth of course it
between forty and fifty eight and all of
a sudden we're starting to look at
maturity and possibly the end of their
life and marketers are beginning to try
to figure out how do you age
boy so think back to when you break a 20
for a 50 year olds were congregating
average agent Rose go right out 60 so
this is one of the interesting pieces
some of you know my background I need
some of the school study physics I
switched my daughter's in psychology i
have now worked in gerontology 30 years
business and so I've got some different
hats David quite but my psychology time
I tried it one of the biggest challenges
I think people have is that way the main
vision the future of aging they think of
a grandparent I think of the way a
six-year-olds used to be our parents had
record rolled in the past with
yesterday's smashes yesterday's medicine
yesterday's point of view about who you
could be when you were settling you're
going to grow old in the future with
tomorrow's breakers and tomorrow role
models and tomorrow's possibilities this
is what 16 hours mikado is a grandfather
i would say Keith Richards over there
the right looks to me somewhere between
100 and 50 would you give another
example 1973 Cara Grande global
spokesmodel for a state ladders into 26
the end of the year which in turn 27
they are told you all this 20-year so
of all excited showing the new louder
spokesmodel for 21st century Katharine
Graham 55 same woman so she was dead in
26 out of 27 in again one last example
70s the rock and roll edition
responsered by the cola company beeps
voice number of left ourselves by coke
pepsi eighties and nineties the beer
companies got involved the Callahans
bank who were sponsored by Budweiser
winners wouldn't fire on under global
reunion tour recently
that's super bowl other than jackson
engineering your mishap yes and i watch
it again with sons for kids and dad
would you have a four-hour erection 12
hour 36 hours levitra viagra cialis
Dominic I would have told you that 10
years ago now this one took me a while
to figure out on my tenth book before
this one for the hit me between the eyes
that people always thought of owners as
being this know sort of democratic
mastic migrated to standard light and
sort of behave the way the folks just in
front of them hat so we were kids you
have some of the Aussie based on the
structure and isn't that their breaks
letter no clean a need and then with our
turn to play around family life nobody
predicted this Jackie love non-marital
connection calm you good news is we have
returned to the Aussie based family
boobers mountain boys are exactly those
countries who are parents who just going
to war with Germany and Japan and
Detroit never saw coming by the way
athlete something similar is about a
flea medicine medicine thinks about this
his generation gonna want that that's
what they're going to buy we'll get to
that I was involved with Iacocca advisor
a hooker when we keep the co-operative
once the minivan of the email me he knew
that this degeneration in either station
wagon we're at a swing the single thing
we had families and kids and dog but we
didn't want station wagon parents had we
need sports utility so we could hit
those speed bumps at Nordstrom's without
any more bad we have you know hope
everybody's got on this play boy if you
can go back to the grocery store 25
start a company business you could not
start do these kind America and of
course it might be the most
extraordinary difference between the
boomers and previous generations our
women our generation educate willpower
knowledgeable more charges relation
which is a non-trivial phenomena
fertility provide knowledge power no
conversely came along with the internet
19 will I think that you have any
website other one generation loves
information fuel by you want to be why
we want to put this out we write play
sir
and now we're on our way amateur and
anybody who thinks that we're going to
hit maturity the same way previous
generations that I think is missing the
fun let me show you some numbers if you
simply look at the demographic portrait
back in the nineteen fifties which age
group grew which declined you would be
drawn to you but look at the 1960s and
looking at the 1970s it let me know you
see a trend for me here by the way
there's really one of the more
interesting phenomena because in most
people thinking they think the real big
breakers gonna come from some new
technology or some amazing new idea but
that the monarchy is flat like a lake
it's not it's up even but a student at a
speed of life so it's not moved it's not
happening tonight it's happening over
the course of time so if you could set
back and watch you happening in fast
motion where we headed and I'll give you
the 20 years friend this is the way the
US and most amount of world demographic
makeup is good change now if you them
back which you now do
what I want to look like a 65 year old
wanna feel kind of card rev connectors
they were dry but people want going to
happen with your bodies on the intern 70
what are the clear ourselves with an
aging population somebody could come out
of the viagra for the mind
so comedians for years it's like you've
got a 76 million pound elephant that's
migrated across the life line which only
goes one way yeah after the past half
century the way most people to pursue
this element they wait for the path
novation Apple did it but I say get out
I'm trying to dig a big hole adulthood
immaturity zone where longevity begins
to service it's hard to know
twenty-three-year-old it would be one
jadis they might be useful 22 year old
but the eight years before you know if
they did a hundred you too so this is a
generation how many of you were born
between 46 we have an enormous mass we
are getting to like the idea of your
life getting anxious about physical
decline will be some of our friend you
seen our parents you knocked out and
we're going to do with adulthood first
you lay out a map of adulthood different
than well similar here to the time skull
paintings historically adulthood has
been linear first reserved for the youth
many were created family and then you
have no leisure before you die you'll
learn one time you fell a lot of Noah's
laughs it's less threatening took your
death do we are you divide out of the
responsibilities honey I'll do this
you'll do that he's always talking about
perfect and then right before you died
you put the cruise not a fact
i disappoint some of you with what I'm
about to say but I actually feel that
the biggest transformation that will
occur as a result of life extension will
be in the way we conduct our lives not
at the end but throughout I think reduce
your death of the way your life plan of
the rise what I'll call cyclic life plan
where people will say that's cool if
you're in an unhappy relationship went
up try to find a new one we're going to
be retired 25 years whenever reinvent
yourself and this is a very interesting
issue this will play after we heard
about 60 minutes so I wonder the
American really safe to walk me around
introduce me to the other people are the
show is that I can like well let's talk
to more people about aging the world
which may actually be true I said can be
said to becoming the most interesting
thing you can survive from all that
before we went on the air and I said I'd
yet you had one person say to me after
street 22 million people all with a
former presidents many world leaders I
get that one person said I like the idea
greater longevity because I'd really
like old-time so what if you a little
longer let you go back to school if I'm
going to live longer I like to be young
the bomber or like to be little essence
for 15 years or better learn the
internet I'd like to start a new company
so that's a very interesting issue as
longevity cause
the old for an extended period or is
good people a different view of the
entire horizon of their own life with
the possibility that there's time for
late blooming second chances new
beginnings do-overs downshifting
upshifting you know the corporate CEO
who becomes a sculptor the sales and
marketing manager who becomes a school
teacher you know the former president
jimmy carter who you can't be mad at
entering an offer it's a look more like
this by the way I'm going to tell you
you know I have to have a ton of books I
know some of you were in the media each
other maybe they are talking about some
technology that because people will be
3000 they want to cover but the idea
that we have an entirely different kind
of life 40 and 60 and 80 not a juicy
you look up Webster's on a five ways to
warm in here if you got the door closed
and a lot of people do it okay yeah
through the story yet but I go man
looking west with our prediction under
the word retirement which is a word that
got largely empowering through the
creation of Social Security which I want
to fight was not designed so that older
people could have a lot of fun of it
later years it was designed because
twenty-five percent versus out of work
for the depression and Roosevelt was a
very smart fellow he knew that unless
you leave old people out by
institutionalizing all day there'd be no
room for the young to get started in de
Mars so retirement was created an AIDS
was picked and you look up the
definition I think language tell me why
it says to disappear to withdraw to go
away that's an interesting model so is
one dimension of life extension which
we're in the second inning sort of a
reconsideration of the idea that life is
sort of like an Everest climb where you
get at the top you're 50 you get bid you
and then you descend and with every year
you're less that's the model or might we
create a different model in which people
think about reinventing themselves
trying
you know the second year old learning
his skill opening a part-time in every
foreign falling more in love in a team
in the environment 30 is it conceivable
that this left a flowchart of frontier
maturity men turn out to be the most
interesting some of our lives I think
this committee definition of retirement
I think they'd already connected his
last three quarters of the century older
people kind of getting out of the plane
being done the average retiree left your
watch 43 hours of television week so
that's an interesting issue if we're
going to create longevity what's its
purpose I've been to so many colleges
where people talk about how to live long
now to a second for what purpose so you
can be young for 80 years that progress
organs if you become more grander
greater to get back that's another
interested in issue because the current
model for educator longevity is it when
you go you're done giving else undertake
we should ask the question boy at sixty
seven or eight years of life experience
twenty years of free time on your hands
we could sure use your help our garrison
were very I one of my mentors talked
about last stage of the black we're
about generativity getting back not the
current model in our culture older
people the lowest volunteer in of nth
root for the country they get thrown
into police nothing wrong with that
they're not quite sure what they want to
be doing with their demands they are the
pioneers they're just exploring for the
first time will have a chance to think
about it and then personal reinvention
in freedom magic reaching a point in
your life or your a little bit free of
some of the
the Rosie your reviews and may be free
of raising children you may be free of
feeling like you got to make a lot of
money or prove something to the world
you may enter into a period of life
making the most powerful decades of your
life in your 50s or 60s or 70s longevity
will commit that make sure you
when I started which is what's going to
happen to the body I my feeling is
what's gonna happen to our life to our
society to our world to our hearts to
our sense of purpose as we move on and
we're not going to live longer in one
day we're not getting our 360 maybe I'll
have to be a consistent i'm not sure but
the idea is with the item with the
possibility of farm life how will I
shape who will let it come and what is
it vs. stop bro before we monitor into
this zone which I'm gonna show you what
I think let's take about 30 seconds
stand up and stretch feel free to
comment on your mind
you're having
one of the challenges is how do we feel
about I'm going to sort of try 4k aging
there's the idea crater or with greater
perspective other people like that
there's the idea of more time I think
people like that but I don't think
people like that pain suffering illness
disease so here's the members of the
Boomer ruminating about the aging
process the group of school volume up
because this is the time they like to
still have your choices I got my son
Chris you're a teenager think you can do
anything and you do twenties thirties
family money 20 40 LED grow under the
chin you're supposed to get to lab one
of your old girlfriends in high school
becomes a grandma 15 have a minor
surgery you'll call by the procedure
what is this
because you can hear any saturdays you
and the wife retired if wandering around
Malta major stroke in the family since
you're making us your wife and stand
with you if we live on but we have no
purpose and you're sucking down
reversals over four tires on this fire
is that a good thing or is it
conceivable little on science potential
biological revolutions we need to create
a psychological social and spiritual
political revolution to mount
so don't get upset at this next life
don't take it personal imagine that
you're the president of flies for
actually so enormously roll the body
changed circulatory problems transvaal
the joints about accosting the veins or
any compare men's bones with mass
density muscle mass diminution is the
client obesity weight problems because
the padam padam shifts too by the way
the idea and if you waiting Evan you
can't receive a calm and take off the
market places with an aging population
greater likely cancer errors in the body
skin wrinkles and become other I think
about if you are the skin product world
or service for all we have an entire
generation with skin is becoming thinner
more if little discolored but it's cool
with that and then you got a world of
Maggie Q the founder of the grid
Hamptons you said you know we want to be
proud of our ripple she's the we're
literally right most wonderful thing
exactly so do you not think is gonna be
a multibillion-dollar zone of
opportunity for people who can deliver a
beautiful skin in comments urinary ecole
hip replacement I'll just
xerostomia you're driving for them out
somebody has planted welcome something
for the mouth to be more always possibly
are we going to see the world with joint
replacement taking long multiplication
of the number of diabetics are we can
see the evolution of treatment of
insulin difficulties in the body I mean
this is a map of the future by the way I
know what it is like yeah I don't want
this stuff okay how would you want to
pay not allowed and any one of these
areas is a multi kajillion dollars
baptism tomorrow probably about the myth
of the phoniest were to film is in some
books the into starting their beautiful
goddess eos who forces in the world but
she fell in love with a warrior ponies
who was going to die so she went to zoos
and she said I'm gonna ask to one wishes
life so what's that grant him
immortality allowed me to live forever
so we said earlier he'd like to The
Trevor fine she says done and as she
completed juices chambers simulation
forgot to ask for help so as the myth
goes the phoniest got older and sicker
and his bones broke his skin rotted he
became commended but he could have died
so that's an interesting issue are we
looking to increase our lifespans but if
we don't buy mechanically increase our
health spans yeah
we already know that as we mature the
likelihood chronic conditions multiplies
so that's to put an incredible strain on
our health care which by the way was not
behind 380 bodies to begin with which to
me is at least one of the other major
Jones of our political arena and I was
saying equal Joker people were too good
but abolition and we thought Medicare
mistakes because we gave description
drug benefits hello you got a train
that's going in the wrong direction put
it cookie ball pops on the Seas doesn't
fix it we have a healthier system that
was designed the diagnosis and treatment
of chronic disease Medicare was not
designed to reimburse for prevention or
the treatment of chronic disease for
long-term care the whole thing is on a
plaque yet the average person things
that you throw more money in a fixed
Medicare what are the major causes of
death heart disease cancer stroke at the
semen volume coincidence actions outside
whiskey cetacean by the way heart
disease council more deaths than all
other causes combined so if you could
somehow impact these apart please even
though by the way to ask the public what
they think the biggest healthier they
say cancer where they want more research
cancers horrible disease heart disease
is more substantial in terms of its
impact on how long we live you want to
have a breakthrough longevity not about
heart disease equally interesting is
what people report they suffer from and
when paying this number one so as you
can look at the athani but with
crippling pain is that your home
looks like this one kind of interesting
we spent about greater percentage of our
gdp or per person dollars on healthcare
mini country the world almost a factor
too so we spent a lot of money on
healthcare so how we do it well somebody
might ask a question other than Ryan
here and others in the room investor
well for sale of money health care are
we produce to help actually not we don't
have a terribly healthy population and
many people think the United States
reigns in terms of longevity these are
all longer than we do and australia
iceland spain switzerland canis meeting
is real friends retelling of the way
they leave a pretty positive german said
before he's going to wait I want custom
reconsider wherever mediocrity with
regard to each other plus our elders
arguing so is the answer to spend more
money on the existing medical system
will that produce a great result may not
we'll get the back
you see because I can easily envision a
scenario where we find ways to keep
people alive long or longer and longer
but simply extend the credible pain and
suffering sickness so that's an
interesting issue is if you're going to
be able to modulate life extension you
want to simply make it longer you want
to take the last year's that extend them
or do you want to take the healthy years
and extend them and compress the sit
here other words would be really the
boss of all things you'd give that some
fun because it's conceivable we're
creating a Jurassic Park we're going to
lengthen life lengthen the disease peers
won't dwell knees but to give you a
sense and other docs in the room then
with each decade the incidence of
various conditions since the multiply so
if the mass in that age which studies
into the surety there's clearly a
multiplication of these conditions
unless there's some kind of
breakthroughs which we were on ending in
a second let me talk about Alzheimer's
just for setting the dementia rate among
the 8500 population in the world right
now is forty seven percent
and how it becomes I'm going to read
Magister viewed on a sort of Master game
so now we come up with a breakage that
nobody has heart disease Travis except
you're going to create 20 million
demanded people I mean in other words if
you don't simultaneously not have
neurologic dysfunction you're going to
blow you're gonna have it it will be the
sink hole into which the 21st century
falls I mean then honestly there's a
million people with America with HIV too
horrible is it evolved of friends loved
ones store million Americans without
side and the projections are the prior
generation it will be 16 to 20 million
and worse instead of eight ten years of
out of Congress it will be 20 to 25
years we will be better at managing
equals holding the other diseases so
then you begin to see way too light
stanchions kind of complicated because
if you get that dial working right but
you don't get this door right that's you
know you're into phoniest country bad
zzz if i take on the future and I told
you that's 16 million we're going to
you
question four
where the car is coming in spending the
money to prevent the disease for the
agent for future generation with number
38 and more benefits and entitlements
and protections was member number one to
wait and we don't forget to think about
where we're heading and start to take
actions early enough we're going to wind
up there
and of course the 85 the best where do I
think we're heading a couple of things
going to Titan which technologies I
can't think of the big ones first
recommends whenever a greater
empowerment and II growth talking about
filming a battle basis of therapy
building a database of procedures
building a database of your condition
and then putting together to your own
viewing plan to follow doctor's orders
now the profound emotion look even an
advertising see that I so ferocious with
vision so you can see a flood of ass
this is the deal I lilia which altered
women are mostly portrayed is you're
seeking to garden you can't see these
times if you know scarce so several
years ago procter gamble launching their
version of the nostril process elated
product and they senior vice president
of marketing of the kind of battling
breast cancer woman and she said these
answer about gardening about come on
this is not it mrs. their campaign a
warrior oh I weapon this is a totally
different mindset the idea that people
are thinking about is my body I'm not
sure if you know what's best for me plus
i'm a shopper in this game i might take
some of this to take some of that by the
way we should be surprised to the
courses with shane generation that is it
into their teenage years and then
adulthood control ladies I said their
automation fertility something happens
for me and I've been a lot of finals
health care so the field in which I've
worked a little more than some others
but all this time that woke up one day
and we were talking about patients then
they became consumers and healthcare
they require to formally known the
patients as consumers some of the new
tools that I think are coming as a side
of the dipole selection first I made up
the space healthy aging by accident I
was doing a project I had a homer and I
call it the Alliance for health and age
Carlson some friends and Rick and when I
was dictating a no we got that my
secretary hood wrong she wrote about
healthy went out healthy aging cannot
help you he was about to seize so the
idea of healthy aging was kind of
provocative but I got somebody to call
it anti-age the fastest-growing
subspecialty of Medicine Brenner
anti-aging medicine I've heard people
think I've heard people call that is
rejuvenated mess and if somehow causing
you to remain young and we heard Mike OS
papa regenerative medicine which is
almost mind-boggling yeah the other you
can reverse aging not just slow it down
or halted what does the fields going to
be is it to be healthy aging which is
kind of romantic it's the second
generation wellness and sweet it's got
the teeth anti-aging which is sort of
pissed off all the doctors
America all trying to get how to make
the kind of money to those guys to start
an egg is it going to be rejuvenative to
make young keep your honors and Kendra I
don't know they they all be happening
simultaneously some of the areas that I
think we should track we could all be
extending our lives took better care of
nestle I know the best not nearly as
exotic as got here an anti-aging
transfusion of some sort I'll give you
one little story I know most many years
ago I today takes years of an ideal
color company called high performance
living I also brought tapes from
themselves and so one day I got all
these customized form letters it said
dear can bike wall are you struggling
with too much stress are you not eating
what you ought to be eating are you not
living life it will optimize your
well-being what that dr. Kendall
you know I mean we can all be lower
hurry for heart disease or cancer
everybody kind of no we don't just don't
do it so that's an interesting challenge
you've got a generation desirous of
beauty of youth it's also kind of
gluttonous undisciplined and easy track
but that's good to keep in mind is easy
trap will come as well fascinated by the
continuum proliferation alternative
medicine when in fact is called
alternative I personally think the world
the nutrition of nutraceuticals
understatement potential probably
because it's less radical and did you
can't get past necessarily a fundamental
but we're learning more about these
micro nutrients and foods that may
actually have human or restorative
regenerative properties food is medicine
the storage of 50 compounds currently a
development that are geared to either
altering some aspect of disease and
aging or even their part of the aging
process itself 450 the pharmaceutical
industry in the way you like to feel
when you hit 50 and 60 and 90 you may
not like them you may like it I had a
mixer set of perspectives I can tell you
the one for the pharmaceutical industry
my son would not know my father then
charge too much maybe today we not like
certain things about the Navy but it was
like those look that wonderful couple of
juice to the movie a day without
Mexicans Mexican
a couple of fabulous documentary I've
received but I read about it they remove
all Mexicans in California for day there
but you realize how important they were
in our eyes if you do fall apart without
our life a lot of people you love
wouldn't feel so good that day is it the
only path no did we eat better exercise
more could give you two different
combinations i'm personally intrigued by
the world of the mind I think that
what's going to happen to our brain in
terms of parkinsonian conditions and
Outsiders memory loss uncharted
territory for the neurological sciences
100,000 Americans approximately right
now injected himself with anti-aging
hormones you probably know people who
are doing I know why and we're doing
thought about and why can I talk about a
lot of friends plus about a thousand
dollars a month so combination usually
you guys testosterone and HGH I think
it's a little bit scary not like in
Vincents without risk a lot of people do
it's so when every time I give speaks
about you know rich families people come
up
so what are you doing I know we got
going so I hi
what I get a book with timothy leary
exerciser he said to my no don't they
won't open jack which I don't and by the
way I say watch what's going on in the
world of sports medicine you know we
often think the nest and will evolve
from its core I think the most evolution
occurs from the perimeter from the
margin you know you what how it happens
you can jump higher and more muscles and
be stronger and it's a little bit early
stage stuff but is it conceivable you'll
be 60 and somebody say look we can take
this smoothie in the morning we'll take
like your favorite / juice it will be a
combination of vitamins minerals and
nutrients and hormones it will cause
your body to feel like it's 35 again and
it will formulate each night based on
your number 7 in your toilet before you
want to sleep so when you get up without
the exact blend of your rejuvenation
drink oh I think that's going to happen
in a decade of course you can already go
on dr. Wilde common 305 is a month get
vitamins blend reduce for your unique
physiology and stage in life and your
hormones move your part of that when we
understand what better
an interesting piece of my how many here
i thought was introduced for the speech
was the fact that while their
reproductive Pony of therapeutic cloning
and probably a poem something different
yeah should have called them something
different because scientists are not
markers i would tell you that when i
started the aging field I couldn't earn
a living so I would be training programs
on creativity innovation in one of my
kind of explore the world all my friends
talking to work for me these are
interesting characters I won't
understand and I learned that there was
fishing and the way that works is you
read a comic matter apart and create it
goes crazy and it creates explosive
energy and these waste matter you write
this little bit spooky but then there's
fusion which is sort of what does and
you bring atomic matter very close
together to create unlimited energy but
they call it the same thing so an
anti-nuclear movement occurred this
shutdown hope we would have an entirely
different world today if you can energy
work to work we would not be in the
Middle East if not we're not shut down
so the scientists in places like
Lawrence lab didn't think what's
happening is the overall religious
people is rising up against clothing and
unfortunately they're putting
therapeutic cloning in the same song the
idea here is my dad's got done because
he's just got blinded he's in his ninth
minute what if instead of being tortured
by always on embarrassed did you go and
give some saliva they grow back a new
pancreas idiot does it would cost 300
bucks over the organ
so we have an ailing organ you get a
place apart it's your own biologic match
replacement parts from your own biology
is obviously a more extraordinary
solution and radiation and surgery and
chemical dosing the crazy stuff we do
now you know I worry that therapeutic
cloning is going to be halted because of
the religious strong genomics billing
faction switch reprogram understand your
own proclivities alter them forth
apparently smash your nutrients and your
carbon cosmeceuticals to be in sync with
your genetic equivocation to adjust for
them and of course you know the amazing
the amazing stuff which is just beyond
imagination and yet so amazingly close
again and I want to say one thing gone
back cause I'm just about at the end of
my comments called paintings there are a
lot of people who believe that it's
God's order if you live a certain number
of years and then you die you started
tinker with that that's not going to be
met that'll be had with a silly grave
concern
and there's a lot of people feel that
the purpose of life is afterlife and you
sit want to extend life well then you're
fooling around with a religious equation
make the abortion that she was a big
issue himself a lot of discussion and
the less people who understand it like
the speakers of this program and to talk
about possibility of healing or
preventing mentioned Parkinson's heart
disease perhaps even aging himself we
may see one of the most extraordinary
potential miracles you professor
I spoke the classic and cosmetic surgery
you happy dad big beard across the u.s.
I've last moment or two years on us just
us us yeah there were real leaders is so
true story so there's about 3,000 people
the room and I'm rocking on stage sort
of a waiting area giving out a word for
SD and there's 10 people getting the
courage awards or their 10 people
getting the best practices current
rewards were people who had had some
horrible thing out of them an explosion
military event door knocker faces cut
out apparently and if the owner of
reconstructive surgery had attempted to
bring them to a normal life they were
lovely people i met them all this hour
all right then these were the hero man
turns out who had the most
extraordinarily profitable plastic
cosmetic surgeon cracker all sitting
there and I couldn't help but notice
that your wife identical
looking at the future of Medicine on the
one hand the fixing the problems and now
the other hand giving people what they
think they want from cash and is it
conceivable that will in the future
whether hormones chemotherapy stem cell
technology may have to go to Singapore
for or maybe your local doctors got some
groove it cooked up in their bathroom
and would it be interested we had a
world very different than our own in
which people not very good we have some
others now but people who could afford
it goodbye themselves that will generate
a different kind of political and
economic hasn't had enough than you I'm
going to jump in this class I'd say it
doesn't caution because when you want
plastic and cosmetic surgery if you go
to the doc and say I want to be just my
face bath I don't need that well then
you just go holland go the other guy
your money if we've all just do a lot of
that where did we wind up here's the
start of the future
you're working 70 why to look like
that's one of the people are beginning
to think about now us do one thing is
250 which i think is very possible Yogi
and really put the word out and any
nominee would and there's other people
like this barrels I never been look
there are people who put the word out
billion dollars what is it a card but
people sang kho paid I just like to be
useful in vital and half hundred years
of life extension with vitality and
contribution this is one model of 17 s
local Bob John Turner hadn't seen over
time the approach 80 body change in my
last commercial before question one of
my kids
our life extension revolution when
compared to a century or two or three or
five overs living longer life than
humans ever imagined possible and lost
it changes all the equations changes
everything but I'm trying to service the
issue it's not simply honor its for what
purpose to what end will I become how
does it society we can figure itself
around four and five and six generations
what are the relative purposes of the
stages of life how much do people take
how much they get but equally important
who could you become if you have those
destinations so we're going to get the
questions I would ask if we can bring
the lights gently up some people are not
shocked by the brightest but let me
first ask you to turn to member sitting
next to you and to share what about all
its mass that I've discovered do you
personally find particularly just take a
moment the people in your body
partner I'll bring it back to one
conversation for one with a couple of
questions by the way there's a book out
here in the bookshop that can just
thought I recommend to you has done
former speakers for Sterling was called
holy fire science fiction novel the best
thing about life extension that we may
play out he refers to the medical
industrial complex for example it wants
to society in just two years maybe it is
already from sue sue swear every
gemstone right there should be some
nasty unintended political consequences
when today's you become virtually
enslaved in order to pay for the old
inch support for the sport holsters to
asses perfect I wrote eight wave III
with a whole chapter I particularly
eight force that I thought that when
young people realized that they were
contributing such an enormous percentage
of their lives to support and
increasingly growing and possibly
undeserving old age set of anomalies
that they would repeal and there he
battle between the generations I have
over the last 15 years come to
still on the first point that is it I
don't think the young generations are
that well organized or Orchestra that's
what happens is that if you're
struggling does not make enough money
you lost a job we want to take it out of
your wife or your neighborhood that it
just creates this sense of frustration
and bitterness drama among what early
connecting my worry is that look like
one of those three stooges clicks where
you know mode reaches out the hit louder
and louder ducks and curly gets it in
the nose that the boomers who've always
computed the dark by the time we get
there is our turn the generations are
the medium will draw that connection and
the boomers will be blamed for being
totally indulgent by the way I comment
that the boomers are currently paying
fifty eight percent of all taxes largely
without complaint are supporting their
parents are putting their kids to school
at the highest volunteer at any age
group shoring up a lot of social
communities and are actually not that
narcissistic when it comes to taking out
but they do believe when their time
comes here you go but they'll be so much
so many of us it's conceivable that the
youth will rise up at that moment but it
has not happened yet second I think the
future still hasn't been written I think
our generation will have existential
crossroads we can either do the AARP
thing and as you grow old we can become
protected we can put balls around
ourselves and we can suck the young
generations driving that's a choice or
we can say perhaps that idealistic
we not only young perhaps the key
consciousness in which we raised in
which we participated leave us with view
of maturity with leaders in which our
purpose in life is to give back is to be
the elders is to be the mentors is to be
the contributors and I still hold out a
promise that are generating rather than
only having been viewed as America's
biggest could still be viewed as
Americans grams how we treat the world
in maturity is still up to us to decide
if we go the first room I think it's the
big bad news the second could be
questioning your version of that another
question from Eric Boyd worry it's
helpful raise your hand to start with it
okay you got a great are you concerned
about the cost of longevity treatments
creating a half an hour such my world
dangerous for were merely unfair
there's um Larry Olsen resentment you
know people today with mayo clinic for
exams and they get healthier food today
have better doctors we've already got
such a separation occurring just started
reading the book last night blanking on
the name letter the first chapter the
author described as a 15-mile train ride
from one aspect of Virginia to
Washington suburbs and with every mile
that built by allege expectancy elevates
one and a half years and got such a
thing but the idea of really pumping it
out I'm the item I have to have mixed
views about it this one part it says I
sure hope I have enough money where I
can keep my loved ones in my
there are some therapy that I can buy
for my dad so that you can see again i
would spend pretty close to everything i
have and what other people might not be
all affording the honest truth is i
would probably try to do whatever I put
some I thought exceed and my mother
would struggle with what she struggles
with what I feel the same way about my
wife my kids probably yes is that greedy
and self-centered yes so am I worried
about a world in which this moment that
people could conceivably control the
cure yeah I think it's coming no
question we question how if we talk
about kind of specific 140 how do you
write on which phone how would you
explain the difference life expectancy
in Sweden Denmark Norway charts they're
very similar populations in very
different ways but I spent time in that
part of the world but I hard enough to
give you this morning's lesson alcohol
how do you think forms of pages in a
song to their parents anything forms of
Ages it will unfold in a slight
extension world you say that I think
we're in a period of profound ages and
now through an older individual trying
to get job clever techniques because
they are young people in their scene
I'll give an example how many of you
like sugar lab like having watch the
good riddance ok so as an interesting
idea people who come out of three star
Mary from the answer came to me so
there's a little bit of a buzz early on
they might be placed because they
weren't voting for the people of color
level and some people they might got a
lot of media attention nervous then
there is it a joke oh they're home folk
beginning but you know if you go to the
website it can't be over 28 and enter
the contest that seems to be perfectly
acceptable everybody if it says you
can't be Jewish you can't be a woman
with dark hair
these people are go crazy we have so
much ages surrounding us that we find
totally utterly acceptable so first I
think it's got we have rooted and broken
down second I think it's got to be
replaced that it can't be replaced with
some romantic 19th century all the
elderly will be loved and respected
because we grown up in a meritocracy you
know that some of your older relatives
are worth being respected and then there
might secretly validated ties into your
question which would be a not a ages of
based on I think you're less than me I
think you're unattractive undesirable
you have nothing to match me with but a
kind of an ageism of bills on this you
seem to have the power and you seem to
have a money and you seem to be
dominated society unfairly which would
be a more of a sort of age work
depending on study for next decade in
this sort of ageism uncovering the lies
and the season with this respect to
older women which I water before it's a
tough battle I mean America is use
yourself to be such a liberal affair
population yet the two industries that
have the absolute highest rate of age
discrimination lawsuits or the
advertising industry and the media so a
very engines of culture creation are the
most dangerous so our view not only
about older people and but who we could
become so distorted a currently that I
old-fashioned guys just got to get up
you gotta keep banging on that and you
gotta keep telling the truth you got to
keep laughing the powers be and get
people to think about it differently and
a lot of the ads you see I'm television
now that are positive years older people
I helped create the products that are in
the marketplace I'll create to my battle
has been want to try to bring an
Enlightenment to this disrespect but I
don't think there's an easy simple
formula for our world clears itself of
ageism but I think the sensitivity will
be how the donors are tomorrow behave
again if we behave in a contributing way
and fairway as a sense of generational
justice I think
game but if it's perceived you know the
greatest generation passes away it helps
the Boomers narcissus be an ugly started
let us that's the neat thing about the
future we get it created for questions
that we read science fiction
respectively questions for you one
notice from the Sean ten years ago we
would have left you out one for
describing the effects of the Opera in
fact tomorrow first described its answer
was it does one Khloe laughing out of
the room for now that we were about 10
years now what would you speculate first
met Karl footnoting a lagger the
medication that would be studied before
regina vascular medication and you guys
know the clinical trials are taking
place and result of coming back right
you can seem to work but when people
were asked to send back 18 month of the
trial that was the only outstanding
piece of information no bc for eternity
side of it so that
side effects locked up what do I think
might happen in the next decade that
right now you would either laughed me or
think the extreme I think in the next
decade Michael let's talk about this one
occur i think we will be able to control
my education I think whether people be
permitted to do it within the United
States and Russia or something to get
the technology I think it will be there
it will be a bit of a wild west because
I ambitious considerations unknown what
else do I think that we will have a
capacity either to get placed in parts
through our organs for a pigs grow them
you know that's going on now that's a
way of getting around the ethical
religious stuff that digs workers are
remarkably similar to humans than there
actually genetically influenced ebay so
that they wrote kidney almost identical
to your own so that if you need a spare
parts a pig in me but nice bacon for
breakfast already got a piece of the
fitting of you but the idea of farming
animals the body parts I think
ok I
Wow the next ten years widening your boy
like I said last month was what a 56
year old or 57 woman gave birth to twins
or I think it's in see the bowl that
when we walked or not at 60 /
seven-year-old will be able to bc
whereas home photodynamic that way yeah
why hit me my cross with germline in the
next 10 years so that you can literally
have Chunkin born you know sort of the
opposite approach your kids so you can
have children born could be sort of like
the Immortals that you might have
children more letter are born with the
capacity to live to which we hundred
years in woodshop something like that
came out of the next ten years and how
the world would be acted ugly pretty
darn in easton last i'd love to see them
to Elsa I would love to see an addition
to a way out kind of well interesting
and provocative stuff man I like some
powerful leader to get up and you don't
like the John F Kennedy everyone we will
see a world without outfitters in the
next four years because I'm extremely
certain about what happens to the mind
if the buy in this longer with the mind
becomes the suction so what I like to
see that what I love see you in ten
years it's like a polio we now no longer
about on resort and by the way so the
many of you know it's not the day
beauties are easy 10 years 20 years and
forth when it begins so we're all on the
track what I like to see that story
history rather than future a little more
me lengthen your now in
basically the demographic frame that
been living with for four years is
pretty much the last century and even
more pretty much the sort of current
life span generation so far reach about
these are trend lines demographics the
city says peaceful people think about
the pieces like 200 succeeding
generation more and more generations
alive at the same time the aging
demographic human creasing it doesn't
just stop perhaps what's the long-term
perspective
articles books and it's a novel if he
gives 150 million years ago million
years in the future which the prettiest
threat um if you speed up these
demographics what you get is a world
largely white European hi folks getting
old and seeking to maintain usefulness
in their old age of width by the way I
think a lot of longevity let expect us
to have a lot of ding who play software
and then you know things Matthew were
quite as good as we go from up to and
then you've got people of power you've
got people in different regions of the
world who are proliferating who are not
having one point two children that you
go to the least five and six seven kids
each and so if you were to speed those
two trend lines up what you see is that
the population configurations become a
particular group of old powerful and
attempting to preserve their youth
nations being taken over in terms of
demographics in population by people of
different backgrounds different
religious views and different ethnic
origins who get the tribal thing
ultimately tribes family on domination
of this planet jointly
look at that same goal than that those
countries Providence turning dark blue
but you do look at the ones that were
yellow and you know you've got beaches
of the world whether you go to a graphic
better wrap for 32 still six seven or
multiplying the world that's fine but
that's kind of saw the demographic hit
the head that's going to happen over the
coming years some pensa coming 40 years
does he keep doing that waiters than
shift perforate is floating we had
talked earlier by football man the birth
rate is actually pulling from six
dominated Europe alright so let's zoom
out which is I don't completely agree
with what's going to happen a couple of
years I honestly it's hard for me to
imagine that it's simply the longevity
story will be the dominant story it's
easier for you imagine issues have you
would indicate availability of resources
peculiar battles among tribes will flare
up and conceivably strange ways so one
when I imagine if none of that occurs
becomes a habit half an hour world you
get along with empower populations
highly educated left of it
and battling those who wanted their way
I know I'm not keeping a satisfying is
it vital I don't have capacity this
moment to think back into the turn for
200 years out I'm or here with these
next 10 to 40 years are going to be
where this phenomenon breaks loose what
happens on the other side of that I
don't even